turn to my right right now and see a man
with 17 NBA seasons under his belt a
former world champ once a champion
always a champion NBA champion two-time
NBA all-defensive first team player NBA
Defensive Player of the Year etc etc and
I'm a New Yorker so it's always great to
see someone from Saint John sitting to
my right good to see Metta World Peace
how are you sir he's good man it's good
to be back yeah you working with Michael
Rapaport when when you here last time
yeah it was funny you know mike is great
great energy and yes he still I see him
long on Twitter and I seen him at the
big three and just like you know full of
energy he's just a great guy so were you
at the big three in staples i watch the
big three but i didn't go yeah i got any
chance ago i was in school and doing a
couple other things so i don't get a
chance to really participate okay what
do you mean you're in school for those
who may not know I'm in UCLA for digital
analytics right now so I won't back to
get my masters and everything and take
it just taking time but I was in school
for the for the summer so I didn't get a
chance to do a lot of things so somebody
who is on campus at Westwood yeah just
looking across the the campus yeah can
see Ron Artest you have like a knapsack
do you have like a book battle book bag
and my laptop and I just you know it was
fun I think it's great just drawn
through yeah I was uh when I at them
that the the season I was uh talking to
magic and magic was telling me he was
gonna bring me back and I didn't want to
retire but I'm like okay what am I gonna
do if this is it and then I woke up the
next morning and I call UCLA up and I
applied for two classes social media
digital analytics and I also took a
business analytics class and Concordia
Irvine okay and you know they were just
something that I was interested in so I
said you know what let me keep going and
see if I really like it and you know it
was it was fun when I attended class it
has Steve Alford reached out to you to
see if you have any eligibility left I
don't have any I mean nothing maybe I
maybe I try it out play with Cody Rowley
okay okay and so what it what what do
you do with a digital analytics what is
that it's interested in so it involves
everything marketing and when I was in
st. John's I was a math major Chris
majors architecture then I dropped that
major then I made you dropped that major
then I majored in math
by that time I didn't care about school
at that time like I'm going to them
being a couple months so I stopped going
to class you stopped going to class yeah
why do I need to go to class you know
I'm going to be a couple months so you
know so and then you know when I look
back at it I wish I would have not done
that I wish I were to take a serious
because I did get my degree later you
know I got my degree and uh but now I
like school and I wish I were that kind
of pay attention more but now I'm back
at it now okay so are you are you done
you think playing back I'm not done you
know this year I want to play if they
don't have me this year I'm not gonna
press it that much you know state the
NBA NBA teams but next year I would like
to come back absolutely I would like to
finish out next year so I'm not that
stressed about this year or you know I'm
not that anxious about this year I'm
ready to play the ship you know all
ready to contribute but if not you know
what next year's the year I really want
to you know get on the team and
hopefully you never know get get the
second ring you know or just you know
get on the team in this finish out 20
years Metta World Peace here on the Rich
Eisen show so were you hoping the Lakers
would would bring you back not the late
well the lake is always option because I
have so many good times here but my exit
made of magic and for me that probably
was my last year as a Laker as a player
you know they they offered me to come
back in some capacity you know maybe
coaching or development or something
whatever and so as a Laker you know
that's over but you know maybe it's some
other teams out there potentially okay
you know I can you know be a part of its
organization in the meantime what do you
think of what is happening with the
Lakers I mean I'm excited I bought two
tickets I didn't really want to ask for
the tickets because I want to go to the
first game I really want to enjoy it you
know so if I'm not playing well if I'm
not coaching I got about two tickets but
I want to go to the game and enjoy a
play with brand then play with Julia's
play with JC and you know I want to see
the the ball brothers I want to see Zuma
the new young boy so I'm excited about
this about the season okay now did I
miss these they're another ball on the
team he said ball brothers oh no the
ball boy oh okay I called him the ball
boy okay
actually a ballboy but you know well I
mean he is he's a boy well like me we're
gonna test to see you know how how how
the Huggies are on right now and if
they're gonna drop fast I mean you
already saw yeah during the draft I mean
you're you're taking classes in social
media you know yeah Ben Simmons and and
Joel embiid were having their fun
watching the VAR ball during the draft
talk and they basically said let's wipe
the floor with this kid essentially when
he gets into the lead yeah you know he's
gonna have a lot of competition out
there people you know you want to have
something to strive for and levar gave a
lot of people in the NBA a reason to you
know kind of target isn't so do you
think that will happen for sure I mean
as far as what you do like what would
you do happen to your veteran I would I
would take it personal I always take a
person who even last year will evolve
you know when they dad I said okay
my son's coming to the Lakers I took the
personal because the guys when that team
was my teammates so I told the guy when
you hear things like that you have to
take it personal as a player if somebody
says something they're coming to take
your spot you have to say something back
and no nobody really said anything back
in the media but if that was me in my
prime I would have been like you know
levar your son is not coming in my spot
you know you know he's gonna be on the
bench like yeah it's competition there
was always all good competition so as a
competitive player I'll take it
extremely extremely personal but I'm not
that type of play I'm not that type of
person in West
those are years gone is the past is the
past so that would be Ron our test would
have said that I mean Metta World Peace
would have said it you know but at this
point I'm more I'm having fun with the
game I'm like my career is almost over
I'm still competitive I workout I'm
having fun with the game yeah I'm having
a great time so I don't think like that
like I used are you surprised Kyrie
asked out of Cleveland well I don't even
know the whole story
I just know Kyrie was going as a's and
cleveland carries in boston I don't know
what happened I saw things on social
media and all type of rumors and how a
surprise and you know I think Kyrie
knees LeBron but you know he's a good
player he's a good player it's gonna be
interesting to see like if he can take
this team to championship mmm do you
think LeBron winds up here in this town
I don't know I mean LeBron
everybody saying LeBron they say in Paul
George he's saying I think I heard Jimmy
Butler didn't I heard you know a couple
of other people and LeBron lives here he
has a house here you know so it's
possible but I don't know mmm better
world peace here on the Rich Eisen show
Tracy McGrady is getting inducted in the
Hall of Fame this weekend you played a
couple years with him what's your what's
your recollection of playing with him I
mean Tracy was a great player you know I
wish he would have played longer but he
was a great player when he was at his
prime him and Kobe they had that one
year where they were neck-and-neck and
comparisons to Michael Jordan Tracy
McGrady was you know really really good
but his body just gave out on him way
too early
he couldn't sustain it but a
hall-of-famer he deserves it he'd bring
a lot to the league and he still doing a
lot of great things good character who's
the best player you ever played with the
best player either play with yeah
Kobe number eight definitely Kobe you
know Kobe just different worked hard and
he focuses on the fundamentals I would
come to the gym sometimes and I round
eight here he'll be in his car leaving
you know again getting to the gym at
about 5:00 working on his Josh steps
head fakes making sure everything's
perfect and that's Kobe if Kobe was on
the team last year then Lavar ball said
his kid was coming he would have said
something about it right well I don't
think so cuz I mean obviously it wasn't
coming for Kobe spot I mean he's a point
guard now if he was saying you know my
son has come in Kobe's prime if you said
you know my son's coming for Kobe spot
you know
kobe absolutely would have said
something you know I missed that part
about the competition that we used to
have back in the days I was speaking to
Lee Angelou actually and I can
compliment to him on how his father
gives so much confidence you know he's
out UCLA playing ball and it's not it's
not enough people like levar you know
like I wish I was in my prime I mean I
would have been going right back at him
on Twitter when I see him face to face
when I see his sons when I was playing
and that's this competition and I don't
see enough people like competing so it
is a
at the fresh air to see to see the ball
brothers interesting it is - why do you
think that is I like him because very
confident no but why do you think
players are in its current all that
competitive anymore I mean even with the
Kobe it is in his final years the talk
was well they didn't want to be
teammates for them because it's such a
hard-ass and a red eyes you know and
whereas you'd want to be in a foxhole
with a guy like that one would think
well I mean it's like it's different so
with Kobe a lot of guys didn't want to
be as teammate maybe because they felt
there wasn't gonna have a chance to grow
Andrew Bynum kind of said that a couple
years ago he didn't have a chance to
blossom but you know I think in terms of
the competition and the trash talk you
know I don't I don't see it enough guys
competing but this summer was actually
good some I saw a lot of guys in the gym
a lot of mba players but is it was in a
gymnast summer and I didn't see it for
the last ten years I didn't see like it
was this summer open runs was amazing in
this summer
so I think the NBA is gonna have a
really good season yeah look last year
last year was was really intense
yeah and you're seeing all these teams
that are loading up to try and battle
the super team I think the competition
you think so because it seems like they
might just be all rearranging the deck
chairs on the Warriors well over the
last couple of years like when I will go
to the gym and I always try to find
where the games are at and and I will go
to UCLA a lot and you still they just
have a lot of runs and but the last 10
years nobody will come to the gym but
this year I saw Harden JaVale McGee
Paul George um Westbrook DeRozan
Westbrook Matt to use like all these
guys was in the gym carry a lot of stars
was playing basketball and not just
enjoying their wealth or sitting home
getting and getting out of shape and you
gonna be injury prone a lot of guys was
in the gym so I think this year you're
gonna see uh you're gonna see a lot of
good ball this year okay yeah no tanking
where you can see any time well you
gonna see some tanking you know
somebody want to try to get the newborn
baby that just came out somebody before
before they they leave their senior year
in high school to take a gig with Duke
which we saw already we saw that just a
couple of months ago it's done analyzed
how the babies it sucks a breast milk
depends on Holly's how to do the breast
milk I like that guy like that baby you
know the class that you can take it UCLA
Wow
before I let you go man what is what's
the hat you got on your head the pandas
friend you go yes it looks like Lakers
colors colors I love the Lakers okay you
know the pandas friend calm is a brand
to inspire people as a brand I kind of
created co-created but a couple people
and we just wanna you know just you know
raise money but for the most part you
know make money raise money give back
same thing I did when I raffle my ring
off you wrapped my championship ring off
we gave the whole 700,000 dollars back
to you know different mental health
institutions and that's what the brand
is about you know it's about you know
giving back and we're gonna keep going
well I've always wanted to ask you this
question so last one for you what why
did how'd you choose Metta World Peace
walk me through that problem well it was
waking my career like right when I got
in the brawl you know I was actually
getting into boxing at that time I was
gonna train with and Angelo Dundee he
passed away
and I wanted to be I wanted to go to
fight him when I was 35 years old I went
abroad happen I didn't want to do that
because you know I didn't want people to
say oh now I met it and now Ron Artest
is trying to box so I just gave up the
whole boxing thing and I was going
through a lot mentally and and it was
hard to recover I was averaging 25 that
year
throwing for MVP and and and I just
could not recover I went from 242 to 273
you know got to Sacramento the next year
and I just wasn't the same I was just I
was okay I wasn't the same and um so as
I leveled off and balanced out you know
I thought a change in my name was
something that would be pretty cool you
know and uh kind of balancing myself out
spiritually and everything so that's
where it all came from Metta World
peace that is Buddhist and world peace
is kind of cool so on your driver's
license it says world peace , Metta it's
Metta and then the last name is world
space peace yeah oh my passport license
cards everything ok need you going you
went into the DMV and filled out
yourself
everywhere DMV the only thing I didn't
do was triple-a so it's still so
actually needed sure if you need a tire
change they say mister our test will
yeah I gotta go to the triple-a office
which is annoying good to see you man
anytime please come back any the pandas
friend calm check it out and learn more
about what Metta World Peace is up to
844 204 its we're gonna take your phone
calls we come back as well still to come
the sneaky good games for the rest of
week number one and we'll cast an eye on
some of the big games for college
football whether there's an upset in the
making that's also to come an hour 3 of
this Friday's show zip recruiter calm
everybody see I'm sorry just let's just
say you started this business right you
got this business going on right yeah if
you got a job that you want to post I
got a spot for you Metta World Peace
okay zip zip recruiter calm okay so you
post your job there okay okay and within
a click one click after you post your
job okay all over 100 job sites gets it
and over eighty percent of the time
people who go and post their job on zip
recruiter com find a qualified candidate
in just 24 hours that's great so you're
looking at hire if you look absolutely
if you're looking to hire absolutely
here's what you're gonna do I'm gonna
write it down for you okay zip recruiter
comm / - you get to use it for free and
then when all the candidates start
coming in because they're man I would
love to work for Metta World Peace I
would love to make sure that this this
hat that he's got on the the pandas
friend want to make you but they they
want to help you with your brand help
you with your business I want to work
for Metta World Peace and they all come
in there's this great handy-dandy
spot-on zip recruiter comm where you can
screen rate and manage all the
candidates in a dashboard easy to make
sense okay very good
zip recruiter comm / - you get it for
free zip recruiter com / - one more time
he tried for free when you go to zip
recruited
/ - I hand that to you Metta World Peace
thank you the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that video be sure to download our app
don't have any memory on your phone
let's start to delete some of those
slo-mo videos you have and you know
which ones I'm talking about